JESSE HAINES: Hi, everyone.
It's great to see all
of you here today.
Thanks for joining us.
My name is Jesse Haines
and I'm the director
of Google Goods, which is
a product and marketing
group that focuses on building
tech accessories for Android.
And it is my great
pleasure today
to have the opportunity
to introduce all of you
to Jessica Herrin, the founder
and CEO of Stella & Dot Family
Brands.
Prior to Stella &
Dot, Jessica cofounded
the WeddingChannel.com when
she was at Stanford Business
School.
She also attended
Stanford for undergrad.
She has won all manner
of awards and accolades,
been on "Oprah" and "The
Wall Street Journal,"
all over the place.
And now in addition to being
an entrepreneur and a CEO,
Jessica is an author.
And her first book, "Finding
Your Extraordinary,"
is debuting this month.
So we are so thrilled to
have you here with us today
at Google Jessica.
Welcome.
JESSICA HERRIN: Thank
you for having me.
I think you might
need to sit there.
JESSE HAINES: Oh,
OK, let's switch.
JESSICA HERRIN: Not
that I have a side
in anything other than audio.
Hello Googlers.
It's great to be with you.
JESSE HAINES: Thank you again
so much for being here today.
So Jessica, we have a
couple of things in common.
JESSICA HERRIN: Our name?
JESSE HAINES: Our
name, Jesse, Jessica.
So that's exciting.
And we also are both
involved with accessories.
I, tech accessories,
just getting started,
and you have built an
accessories empire, which we're
excited to hear all about.
So I want to talk a
lot about the book,
but maybe we could start by just
hearing a little bit about how
it all began.
You've been an entrepreneur
since you were very young.
So tell us a little
bit about how
you got from your beginnings
to where you are today.
JESSICA HERRIN: Well when
I started my career out
of college and I think about
how incredibly fortunate I
am to have been born in the
US and going to school right
at the time when women
earned degrees equal to men,
and I go to school in
the heart of Silicon
Valley, the commercialization
of the internet,
right when Google
was being formed as
well, in the same neighborhood.
And so in many ways I think you
could have walked into a pole
and become an entrepreneur
in that climate
and that environment.
And that was
certainly my interest.
And out of school, I went to
work for technology startups.
And I learned a
tremendous amount.
I loved what being in
enterprise software,
at the time, allowed
me to do, because I
did a whole bunch of things that
I had no business doing inside
of a small company.
And I never really felt like I
had to be qualified to go do.
I had to go do it
to get qualified.
And so it was a great hyperdrive
experience early in my career.
And then I went back to
business school at Stanford.
And I really went there
to be an entrepreneur.
So when I wrote
the business plan
for what became
WeddingChannel, we actually
got called out in a
competition by Kleiner Perkins
and ended up getting
funded before I graduated.
So I dropped out to do that.
I went there to become
an entrepreneur,
not to get a pedigree.
So it didn't seem
like risk to me.
It seemed like efficiency to
get that done at the time.
And there was a real window
to jump through and start
that particular
business at that time.
It was the idea for
WeddingChannel, which
is an aggregated gift registry.
Think back at the time,
this was before retailers
were on the internet.
It was very much when Yahoo
ruled the world of search.
So you can date
that in your minds.
And so I worked at a
enterprise software company
that was aggregating price
and availability for computer
parts.
And I just sat
there and said OK,
what's going to go online early?
We don't have bandwidth.
People don't trust in
ecommerce at the time.
So how can you take that
and apply to the real world?
I'm like gift registry.
Gift registry, somebody's
already picked it out.
The shopper doesn't care.
It's just a price based
on the relationship.
It's a large market.
Technology isn't used
much by retailers.
They're going to need somebody
to come in and show you
how to do it.
So it was this very
analytical, textbook,
find a market opportunity,
use technology to disrupt it.
Build a software platform.
And then we turned it
into a content platform,
and ultimately merged
with WeddingChannel,
and then sold it to The Knot.
So I did everything
right academically.
And at the end of the day, did
not feel successful at all.
I created commercial
success but didn't
care about the mission
of the company.
And then I did the real
soul searching of saying OK,
if I'm going to work that hard,
because at that time I did.
I worked every day and night.
I also wanted to
become a mother.
Didn't know how I was going
to reconcile those two things.
I wanted to make sure that
the next business I started,
I felt soulfully
connected to the purpose.
And when I was there, a lot
of people reached out to me
and said, what's your
best business advice?
We'd been on "Oprah"
and the "Oprah" version
of the story looked great,
looked like the American dream.
But the reality is
behind the scenes
it was a bit of an
American nightmare.
And so I didn't have
good advice on how
to democratize
entrepreneurship, how
to create an experience
where I wasn't saying OK,
go get a specialized degree.
Raise venture capital.
Work every night and weekend.
I mean, what kind of
advice is that really when
someone says what should I do?
So I wanted to think
about reinventing
the home based platform.
Yet when I looked at that
industry, it felt very dated.
It felt made for
a 1950s housewife,
and it did not use
technology at all.
And so I just went
through this experience
of working with
the retail industry
and bringing in
ecommerce, knowing
that you could work
for direct selling,
and recognizing
that technology was
going to completely change it.
So what Stella & Dot
really is, is a few things.
It's taking my
technology background.
First I say, of
everything, we're
not an accessories company.
We're a people company
because it's purpose driven
and it's about creating
flexible work for women
and a few good men
and reinventing
flexible entrepreneurship.
So we're people first.
We're a technology company
because we're really
a social selling
platform that spans
several brands across
women's lifestyle businesses.
And we have a killer
design in product.
But really it all
stemmed from my desire
to be incredibly connected
to the purpose in my work.
And to do what I
learned in business
and as an entrepreneur,
but apply it to something
that really, head and
heart came together.
JESSE HAINES: So
cool, and I love
this concept of sort of
democratizing entrepreneurship.
Tell us a little
bit about-- unpack
that a little bit in terms
of how this-- the model does
seem dated.
How does technology
play into it?
I think that [INAUDIBLE].
JESSICA HERRIN:
It's mostly when I
look at just women in
business, and really people
who are impacted by
that, which is just
the children they're raising,
the partner that they're with.
So much is enabled when there's
a little bit of extra income,
it could create a lot of
opportunity for people.
So I knew that flexible
work had to exist.
It has to exist for people
who-- 80% of our entrepreneurs
actually, this is
their side gig.
They have other full or part
time jobs outside of the home.
But they have incremental needs
that they need to pay for.
So it's students who are working
during the summer, teachers
who need jobs outside of that.
One of our leading
sellers is an OBGYN.
And she does this
because in her day job,
she's so frustrated by the
lack of recognition and joy,
even though she loves
delivering babies,
she hates administration
and bureaucracy
and always being told
her charts are wrong.
And she loves this outlet.
And it also taps into
this other side of her.
So there's a lot
of need out there.
But if you look at the
models of the past,
there was almost
everything wrong with them
in terms of the
business model, it
would be too easy for the
person getting in the business
to get in trouble and really
be in the business of buying
inventory rather than selling.
And you really take care
of that with policies
and ship to customer and
really just changing everything
about how we work as direct
to the consumer versus selling
through the distributor.
So there's no quotas,
no territories,
and completely flexible income.
But with technology, if
you look at our newest
brand, Keep Collected, which did
$45 million in its first year.
It's on the pace to
triple in its second year.
If you're picturing
an old school party,
that's not it, right?
They have a mobile app where
they do a virtual design.
They personalize it.
They share it to social.
That gets [INAUDIBLE].
So it's all through
digital tools,
because we're trying to
take this very busy person
and say OK, you
got an hour today?
How do we make you productive.
And that's why I fell
in love with technology.
It's why I loved, as
nonsexy as it seems,
that's why I freaking
loved making enterprise
software for bars
back in the day
because you take this
person and superpower them.
They would have no information
at their fingertips
and it would take them
a day to do something
and it would be error prone.
You could really
take that technology
to superpower a person.
So that's what we do
in our businesses.
It may seem like it's softer
because its accessories,
but actually everything that
you're doing on the sales side
and really customizing
the experience--
and then there's also an
entire online university
and incentives platform.
Because for flexible
entrepreneurship,
you've got very time
limited people that
need all motivation, no
management to go do something.
And so all of the triggers
and the incentives
and the recognition
is really powerful.
So knowing what it is, I
can tell if your sales are--
if your average event has a
few less orders than somebody
else's, I can look
at that and say,
you're not inviting
enough people.
I can look at the data
and say oh, you need
training on hostess coaching.
I can also look at
the data and say,
I can see your average order is,
you're not finishing the look.
You need to let me
coach you on how to say,
would you like
earrings with that?
So there's just a lot of
power of using technology
in a classic model
to help that person.
And why that's so
rewarding is that person
is trying to pay for
fertility treatments.
So helping them be really
profitable is really rewarding.
JESSE HAINES: So cool.
So you are very
busy, and yet you
decided to write this
book in your spare time.
Tell us a little bit
about what motivated
you to take the plunge
and put all your learnings
and guidance and--
JESSICA HERRIN: Well I
did not write that book
because I wanted to be an
author, that is for sure.
I love my day job
as CEO, and that's
what I want to continue to do.
So I became convinced to write
the book by the phenomenal team
that is here today
because I've come
to see that in the
businesses that I've created,
it has really not been just
because I've been successful,
its been because I've had the
ability to develop success
in other people.
And I've seen the story
unfold in which I've
come to believe that
there are some key traits
of an entrepreneurial spirit
that each one of us have.
It's part of our human DNA,
and that you can hone it.
And whether you want to
advance in your career
inside of a company,
whether you actually
want to start a
business, whether you're
leading in your community
and your family,
I believe these key
success traits can
be developed in other people.
And by far the biggest
reward I've gotten
is seeing an impact on
making somebody else more
successful in their life.
And true success,
not just a title
on your resume and money
in your bank account,
but happiness in your heart
and peace in your mind.
So it became for
me an opportunity
to try to extend outside of
our community, where I've
seen it work thousands of times,
and help other people find
their extraordinary.
We take an ordinary
person and help
them do extraordinary
things by cultivating
their self-confidence, because
it has to start with a belief
that success is not
just for somebody
else, that it is in fact for me
and that I can, in fact, change
the course of my life.
And then put in
place a framework
of the six Ps of
entrepreneurship,
starting with passion.
Got to have it.
You've got to have a
path to make it real.
You've got to have the
right positive mindset
so that you learn how to
see opportunities and not
obstacles.
Having the right
people around you
to help lift you in other
ways make it, worthwhile.
The perseverance to keep going,
the productivity to get it
all done in a day.
So putting that
framework out in a book
is again to try to help other
people be a guide to creating
their own success.
JESSE HAINES: For
somebody who is working
in a corporate
structure-- and you've
told some of these
stories in the book-- how,
when you're not necessarily
actually an entrepreneur but
working in a big
company like Google--
which obviously our culture
is very entrepreneurial,
but it's still a big company.
How do you kind of
apply that framework
to a large corporate structure?
JESSICA HERRIN: Well absolutely.
So there's two things on that.
First of all, you are
a leader and the world
is awaiting your instruction.
And that has nothing to do with
the size company you're in,
what your title is, and
what the org chart is.
Leadership is something that
you unleash on the world.
And opportunity accrues to those
who see that and believe that
and act like that every day.
And I had this experience,
which I am so grateful for,
because more valuable than
I would say my education
was in a formal institution.
After doing a startup
at the age of 24,
when I was really
naive and pretty
much knew very little-- even
though at the time, of course,
at that age person you
think you know everything--
a mentor said to me,
listen, if you ever
want to go run and
build a large company,
you should actually work at one.
I only worked at tech startups.
And I said, that sounds
like a good idea.
So when I wanted to have a kid,
I followed my husband to Texas
where he went into
venture capital,
and I worked at Dell as
a middle manager at Dell.
And there were some
of those things
where I felt like I lived
inside of a Dilbert cartoon.
And that was an
incredible company.
Google's one of the
world's best companies.
And yet, of course
it's a large company,
so of course there's
bureaucracy and meetings
and all that other stuff.
But let me tell
you, I couldn't be
doing what I'm doing today
had I not had that experience.
But I also couldn't be
doing what I'm doing today
if I didn't show up every
day inside that organization
and be a leader and
be my best, and not
get frustrated by bureaucracy,
but find an opportunity
to add value.
And I think that comes
from being raised
by a single dad who had
an immigrant mother who
was educated in the
fourth grade in Italy.
He started having a paper route.
He's an engineer now, got a
master's degree in engineering.
But he had to work to
put food on the table
when he was in the fourth grade,
and put himself through school.
And so just this DNA
family we have, we
have this intense work ethic.
Like if you were cashing
a check from somebody,
you don't act like, what
have you done for me lately.
You show up and say,
how can I serve?
You got a problem,
I'll solve it.
It's the Vanilla Ice
school of thought.
Like OK, I am here.
I am lucky to be here.
I'm going to find
the biggest need,
and I'm going to solve it.
And I think sometimes in a big
company you can get frustrated.
But if you go at it like look,
opportunity is all around me.
How can I go add value
and be entrepreneurial
within that giant beast,
you will make it magnificent
and have a tremendous impact.
So I think that big companies
are critical to a learning
development, whether you want to
be an entrepreneur, whether you
want to make an impact.
But being entrepreneurial
within that company
is really, really important.
JESSE HAINES: Once
of the things you
talk about is success and
defining success for yourself
and not falling prey to
sort of society's definition
of success, which maybe
is measured more in kind
of money and promotions.
I love the way that
you actually define
the success of
your company, which
is I think how much
you paid out to--
JESSICA HERRIN: The business
owners, that's right,
JESSE HAINES: --your
business owners.
And I love that idea,
but it's hard in a world
where there is that societal
pressure around how much
are you making,
when are you going
to get your next
promotion, and so forth.
So what are some
tips that you offer
around kind of how people
can define their own success?
JESSICA HERRIN: Well I did
it the wrong way first.
I achieved success in
other peoples' eyes,
and then I had this feeling
every day going, is that it?
And so I'd sit there
and think, oh I've
checked off this resume.
I've checked off this list.
And yet, I'm not really happy.
And life is short.
And it's too short not to love
what you do, why you do it,
and who you do it with.
And so if you're always
looking left-right
for external validation
on other people
saying I anoint
you successful, you
can feel like there's
something missing.
And so I think that,
one, you've got
to be willing to ask yourself
these very big questions
and not be afraid of getting
the wrong answer, or the answer
that you don't
want, which is, do I
feel soulfully
connected to what I do?
And if no one paid
me, would I bound out
of bed in the
morning to do this?
Now I'm not saying you
should confuse passion
for a job on the
unicorn farm where
you don't have to wash
windows and it's not hard work
or there's not meetings
and bureaucracy
that you put up with.
But you just have to make
sure that the kernel there,
the core is really worthwhile.
And so I had to quit
and go do something
that people thought
was crazy, right?
When I was the internet
poster child in Silicon Valley
and I quit to follow my job,
my husband's job to Texas,
have a baby, become
a middle manager,
and then started making
jewelry out of my living room,
I had to risk a lot of
people being like oh, there
goes another one dropping
out or doing something female
or saying something derogatory
about what I was doing.
But at the end of the
day, I had to say look,
there is a very short list of
people I am trying to impress,
and I am on that list.
Other than that, it's the
few people that I love.
We spend so much time trying
to impress other people,
and actually other people
don't even care that much.
They're not even
thinking about you.
They're too busy
thinking about what
other people think of them.
So I think you just have to
have a very active discussion
with yourself on
what matters to me.
If I were to look past
my future I actually
outline very tactical
steps and exercises
in the book around mindfulness
and doing certain things
like asking your
future self what
you want to be
remembered for, working
backwards in time--
what will matter
to me at the end of this year?
Will I have done
[INAUDIBLE] to action it?
Because I think it's a
discipline to think that way.
It's not a, I go away
and have a spiritual guru
moment where someone
says, this is your path
and this is your passion.
Aha, you're done.
It's really a
practice that you keep
present in your life to make
sure that you are really
dreaming bigger.
It sounds cheesy, but it's true.
You've got to ask yourself
these really bold questions
to come up with
the right answers.
JESSE HAINES: You're a mom in
addition to all your many jobs.
And you write in a
book about a time
when you asked another
female CEO for some advice
about starting a
company and having
a family at the same time.
And I believe her advice
to you was, don't do it.
How did you react
to that advice,
and what is your
advice for women who
want to do all these things?
JESSICA HERRIN: I'm very
honest about it, in the book
and in life in general.
Because I love speaking
at business schools
and communities of younger
people in which they haven't
yet gone to that phase of
having family and work together,
and they often ask
me, well, tell me
what was the sales
trajectory of the business?
What was really the
inflection point?
And they assume it's
access to capital
or some change in the market.
I finally stopped breastfeeding.
I could really travel more.
And when I had kids,
they really have you.
You don't have them.
I was hesitant to do
my second business
the way I did my first one
in which you raise venture
capital, you really commit
to somebody else's timeline
around liquidity
and exit strategy
and growth of the business,
because I wasn't sure
how I would feel
as a working mom.
So I very purposely went
slow those first couple years
and really focused on doing
out of my living room.
One, because I knew the
business needed a soul.
This type of business
really does benefit
from me being able to say look,
I did it out of my living room
while I was pregnant and
had another full time job.
You can too.
So I proved that to myself
and I proved it to others,
and there was value in that.
But when I had my
first daughter--
she's healthy as an ox now.
So just so you know,
everything's fine.
But she needed to have heart
surgery when she was little.
And so all of a
sudden your timeline
that's on some kind of pro forma
looks like-- like who cares,
right?
I care only about this.
So you need to be
able to recognize
that businesses are going
to ebb and flow around life.
So I went to an investor.
This was easier for me to do
again as a serial entrepreneur,
because I went back to a
partner who had been on my board
at WeddingChannel and said
look, I'm going to do something.
I can't tell you how fast.
But I can tell it's going to be
big and it's going to be great.
And I know it's going to
change a lot of lives.
And oh by the way, I'm
about to have another baby.
You in?
And luckily we had worked
together and he goes you're in,
I'm in.
But I very much have
communicated from day one
that this was going to
be mission first, that I
was going to be a mom first.
I still consider myself a mom
working, not a working mom.
My family comes first.
But it was really
challenging in the beginning.
And the biggest challenge
of creating this business
was not competitors or product
or production or people,
it was my own internal
guilt as a working mom.
Because type-A people that
are the type of people
that are going to go
be a driver and start
a business are very
hard on themselves.
So I was that super mom
trying to make the baby food
and do everything and greet
my husband with a kiss
and make dinner, and
almost died alone on I
can do it all island.
And I very much
disclose in the book
how I had to came to
that breaking point
with my husband
and partner and was
like OK, everyone's level of
service is being downgraded.
And we are going to have
to rework how we do this.
So there's a real honest
journey about what it's like,
and I think it's very
relevant to men and women.
Because the idea that men are
taking paternity leave, I love.
Because even 10 years
ago, that was just
never talked about or seen.
So I think today's
group of people
are going to be far
more coparenting and far
more focused.
It is really the bedrock
of life and happiness
is the people that you love.
And if you want those
people to be happy,
you've got to be really
thoughtful about what
load you're carrying,
how you're splitting it,
and how you're able to
still be family first,
but not dim down your dreams,
and be able to have two
people with ambitious careers.
JESSE HAINES: I want to talk
a little bit about that,
but I also want to
let the audience know
that we want to open this up
for questions for Jessica.
So feel free to start making
your way to the microphones
if you have questions.
Just on the topic of working
it out with your partner,
obviously that's a really
important relationship.
And with two working parents,
what are your tips there,
and how have you
negotiated with him?
JESSICA HERRIN: Well,
so first of all,
I think there was another book
long ago, "Men are from Mars
and Women are from Venus,"
which seems to be very accurate.
And what I learned
with my husband,
it was actually
advice given to us
by our reverend, which we kind
of rented one from the internet
to get married.
So this was not like a
spiritual guider for us.
But it ended up that
Reverend Vargas' advice
during our ceremony
ended up being
the most pivotal in our marriage
when he told us that marriage
is about taking the
other person's burdens
and making them half as
heavy, and their joys
and making them double.
And my husband would be will
willing to do that, but I
was hoping that he would
just figure this out
or it should be so obvious
what he should be doing,
and why doesn't
he just intuiting
that I'm doing too much
and he's doing too little.
And actually, you've really
got to be incredibly explicit.
And so whence I was able
to clearly articulate, one,
I don't have to apologize
for being a mom who
wants to start a startup.
That doesn't make
me less of a mom.
I can feel great about how
I want to impact the world
and still feel great
about being a mother.
So when I figured that out
and got over that guilt,
and then said to my husband,
look, this is what I want.
This is how I'm
going to be happy.
Can you help me?
And he does,
because he loves me.
We've been happily married
for 17 years, together for 21.
And we had to negotiate, OK,
this is what this looks like.
Every time the kid
goes to the doctor,
it is not default
my responsibility,
and then maybe you could
do me a favor if I'm busy.
It has to be an assumed
equal partnership.
So I talk a lot about
that, like the real tactics
of negotiating that.
But we've also traded off
at times in our career.
I moved to Texas for him.
He moved this.
And I can tell you at
the end of my life,
I am not going to remember every
moment of what our revenue was
in that quarter or what
magazine we were on
or business accomplishment.
But I will remember, what
will be most valued to me
are my children and my husband.
And so I just always
keep grounded in the fact
that these are the people
that I want to make sure
I connect with.
I think the other
thing that we all
need, regardless of
what your role is,
is remembering the
connection of quality time
and making sure that you're
still courting that person.
When I come in, I'm
not on my phone.
I am still hello handsome.
And that's, I think,
really critical to keeping
any relationship
alive, not even just
a parenting one, spousal
one, and friends.
JESSE HAINES: So you are
a serial entrepreneur,
and you've built this business,
which is now just growing.
How do you continue to cultivate
your own entrepreneurial
spirit?
Do you at times want
to-- and obviously you've
added new brands to the
Stella & Dot family.
How do you think about nurturing
that entrepreneurial spirit
while still growing
this big company
and balancing between the two?
JESSICA HERRIN: While as
the company has grown,
my role has changed
considerably.
And I do think to
grow the company you
need to grow yourself.
I'm an entrepreneur by nature.
And I often think
when people say
why'd you be an
entrepreneur, I don't know
I'm 5' 6 and I have brown hair.
It just turned out that way.
I'm wired to do that.
I've always looked around the
world and seen how I want to be
rather than how it is.
And I have just almost
a tic like desire
to go fix it and change it.
So that's how I started.
But to grow a
business and actually
not have it be about
just what you're doing,
it really is about other
people and shifting that
into cultivating the
entrepreneurial spirit
in others.
And that's been
far more rewarding.
You can get real bored
of yourself fast.
And it's far more
rewarding for me
to shine the light
on other people
and watch them thrive as a
leader and an entrepreneur.
So that's been my
focus now as a CEO.
It's not our top line revenue,
it's the growth of our people.
And it's yet still--
a friend of mine
who gave me the great
advice-- who actually told me,
when I was struggling with, OK,
I've got nine direct reports.
How do I manage this all--
was that just because you're
in charge, doesn't
mean you-- really,
it sounds very
glamorous, but you
sort of default into
whatever hole you're missing.
So you have sort of
20 jobs at all times.
And I always start to change
the way I think about that.
How do I make sure that I'm
doing enough of what I love?
And yes, I'll take care of
these other responsibilities,
but there's nothing
wrong with going
to get other people
to go do these things.
And maybe you're
even better at them.
But if you have a
comparative advantage
in doing something else
that you uniquely do
or that feed your soul so
that you can have energy
to do all these other things,
that's a great strategy.
So part of launching these other
brands and part of the role
that I play in them is
really feeding my need
to create from scratch,
yet also fulfilling
what I have found
to be-- I never
thought there would be
anything grander than being
an entrepreneur for me.
But that's not true.
I have found far more purpose
in being a true leader.
In the early part
of my career, I
can tell you I sucked at that.
I was not a great
people leader, and I
share some of that
in that journey,
and then ultimately
waking up and recognizing,
this is the way to make
an impact and grow.
JESSE HAINES: Any questions
from the audience?
We've got plenty-- oh, great.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is more of a
tactical question I guess,
but you're obviously building
a lot of different kinds
of businesses.
How did you go about
sourcing the things
you needed as far as
like manufacturers or web
development?
How do you even start to
do that kind of stuff?
JESSICA HERRIN: You
kiss a lot of frogs.
You just go out there and
it's volume of activity.
And so if you think about
the businesses I have done,
first I was in
enterprise software.
And if I knew
anything, it was just
about software development.
And then to parlay
that into creating,
yes, a software company, an
internet consumer company,
but in the wedding space, I
had to go out there and find
everybody who was an
expert at weddings.
And how did I do that?
I literally, who do you
know that's in retail.
Who do you know
that's in the thing?
And I just kept asking.
But it's that concept of
prospecting where you're
going to go ask 100 people
to find 10 that are relevant
and one who's going to turn
out to give you something
that you move forward on.
So it's just a massive
amount of networking
and putting yourself
out there and being
willing to kiss a lot of
frogs, have a lot of meetings.
Same thing when we
went into skin care.
I started that
business the same way
that I've started
every other one.
I've got to go find people
who are the best in that.
And that took years of looking
and research and development,
adding someone to our board that
had that relevant experience,
meeting with tens
of people in order
to go identify
the right sources.
So I approached it truly
like an entrepreneur,
which is why you--
it wouldn't matter--
well I want everyone
inside this company,
and every company to be
incredibly entrepreneurial is--
And that's what I learned from
my dad, who didn't necessarily
have access or connections.
He was just like, I
want to teach myself
how to be a builder.
Great, let me crack a book, get
a magazine, go talk to people.
So it's not that complicated.
You just have to keep-- it's
a massive volume of activity.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JESSICA HERRIN: You're welcome.
JESSE HAINES: Any
other question?
All right, I've
got my-- oh, yes.
AUDIENCE: I feel
ridiculous in my jacket,
but it's cold in here.
JESSICA HERRIN: No,
it's very cold outside.
You get a little extra dose of
winter going on around here.
AUDIENCE: First of
all, thank you so much.
It is a privilege
to have you here.
My name is a Jen,
and I am a 12 year
Googler, which is crazy to say.
JESSICA HERRIN: Congratulations.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
I am very proud of that.
So entrepreneurship,
I love the notion
of democratizing
entrepreneurship and making
it accessible.
I'm curious to know,
so you've innovated.
You've added new product lines.
What's the next thing?
What are you going to fix next?
JESSICA HERRIN: It's
really this is it for me.
When people ask me my exit
strategy for my company,
I think oxygen tank
and a stretcher,
because my purpose
doesn't need to change.
Will I continue to
expand lifestyle brands
on this platform and the
social selling model?
I think if you don't
innovate, you die.
So will we evolve our products?
Will we evolve the sales tools?
Will we evolve the
experience for the consumer?
All of those things will change.
Right now, we've
launched three brands.
Two of them are brand new.
So I want to give
them all the oxygen
they need to grow into
their full potential.
Because if I keep diluting it
without putting the same detail
and love I put into the first
one out of my living room,
they won't survive just because
we can rest on our laurels.
I've got to go out
there and nurture those.
But to me, what's next is this.
It's continuing.
I can't wait to have the party
in which we're celebrating
a billion dollars paid.
So that's what's there for me.
And I would say this book,
"Find Your Extraordinary,"
is what's next.
Again, it's recognizing
that my joy comes now
from seeing that we could be
a spark in someone else being
an entrepreneur or
helping them grow.
And so putting that
out into the world
is the start of a movement
for me around defining success
as happiness, cultivating
entrepreneurial spirit
in other people, giving a
message to women for gratitude,
not guilt. And I would
love to take this further
into a platform where
some of those resources
become available
for free outside
of our family of brands,
just so catalyzing that more
development.
AUDIENCE: Actually that brings
up another question for me.
You mentioned early on
this online university.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
JESSICA HERRIN: Absolutely.
So we do have an
online university
within each of our brands.
So when you log
in to the lounge,
whether it's Ever
Skincare, you're
going to learn how to become
a skincare specialist.
And it has a all online
learning platform
to train somebody who
comes to us knowing
nothing, whether it's about
sales or time management
or goal setting or the
product itself, or the tools,
there's an online
university there.
So we don't just provide
the product to sell,
there's a whole platform.
But what I have come to see
in training tens of thousands
of people is it's not the
how-to that prevents people
from getting what they want,
it's that the will to do it
and the will to get
back up and do it again
after the first time or the
first 10 times didn't work.
So when I thought about
writing this book,
it was very interesting,
because initially I
thought long and
hard about wanting
to show that yes, I could
write a serious business book.
I think as a woman
in Silicon Valley,
you still sometimes have
that desire, that almost
reflex to try to prove
yourself and wanting
to go write that very
academic theoretical business
book to show the
world how smart I am.
But I realized it's not what
the world needs from me,
because there's lots of
framework books and things out
there like that.
But the reality
is, I think you've
got to start with the how
do you cultivate someone's
self-confidence and their will.
Because it's the
will to go do it
that is what trips
most people up.
So with our university,
the online university,
it spans a lot of topics.
And it literally talks
about mindfulness
and positive intelligence
and time mastery
in addition to just the actual
tactical things around selling
or coaching other people.
So yes.
And if you go to
our conferences,
our most popular workshops are
productivity, time mastery.
And I realize,
this is an epidemic
of people feeling time
starved and like they're
juggling too many balls.
If for our company we could
just put that out there
for people to access,
I'd be happy to do that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JESSICA HERRIN: Thank you.
JESSE HAINES: One of the
great things-- and thank you,
I'm so glad you didn't
write an academic business
book, because this is
such a pleasure to read.
And I think one
of the reasons why
so many of the things
that you talk about stick
is because you anchor them
all with really great stories.
And you talked about how
you've sparked entrepreneurship
in so many people.
Are there any stories of
individuals that maybe you
could share with this group?
Because it's amazing.
JESSICA HERRIN: Absolutely.
There's ones I love.
And I often think
that people are
predisposed to think that
success is for somebody else
and not them.
And it has something to do
with their circumstances that
is going to prevent
them from going
to do something extraordinary.
And yet there are countless
examples and stories in here
of people who have no reason to
succeed and yet did it anyway.
And so some of the stories in
that book, one that I love,
is the one of this
guy Juvenal Chavez.
I met him at the Ernst
& Young Entrepreneur
of the Year competition.
I was very flattered
to be up for the award.
But then when I met him--
he was also up for it--
I wanted to be like, vote for
Juvenal, vote for Juvenal.
This guy is amazing.
So he was a
schoolteacher in Mexico
had a young son, decided
to come to America.
Didn't speak English at all.
Here could get a job
as a bartender at night
and was a janitor by day,
but had the American dream.
So if you look and
say, is this person
going to go do
something amazing,
you'd be like no, the
odds are all against you.
You're an immigrant.
You don't have any money.
You don't speak the language.
You have no connections.
Right when he got
a huge promotion--
he was local at Stanford,
so he got this job
where he was going to make
$14 an hour working in a lab.
So he was going to get to clean
test tubes instead of toilets.
So he was saying this
is a massive step up.
There's some safety
there for my family.
I'm going to take this job.
But his brother-in-law said,
let's go start a meat market.
You know, let's just try to go
down and create this business.
And he went down there, and it's
this really rough neighborhood
of East Palo Alto
back at that time.
And walks in, and it just reeks.
There's maggots everywhere.
There's rotten meat.
And he's like no freaking way.
I'm out of here.
This is mad.
Why would I try
to do this instead
of taking this other job?
And he was with his
wife at the time, who
I think has that magical gift.
It's one of the pieces
of positive mind,
was how do you look at
something, like literally
rotting meat and maggots,
and not see what's there now,
but see what could be.
So out in the parking
lot where he marched out,
his wife turned to him and
said, Juvenal, look again.
Don't see what's there,
see what you want to see,
and tell me what it is.
And he looked and
he closed his eyes
in the direction of
the place and said,
I see a market
where people could
shop like they do at home,
where the Latino woman is
cooking for a lot of people.
She shops more frequently.
It's a lot more friendly.
It's sort of a smaller format.
It has different types of food.
And it's bustling.
And he had the
vision in that moment
for what would become Mi Pueblo,
which is now a $300 million
grocery store chain
in Northern California
that he now operates
with his three sons.
And I just think that
that powerful story just
illustrates what's possible,
you know, how lucky we are
and what is truly possible.
And you don't have
to have anything.
But if you have the
entrepreneurial spirit,
then you have the ability
to see what could be
instead of what is.
You don't spend your time
in frustration and fear.
You experience it, but you
quickly recover and go back
to imagining what you want.
So that's one story that I love.
There's the stories of one
of our business owners,
this woman Cindy
Rhodehamel who's
exactly what you would think
of if I said mom from Ohio.
She's this total mom who had
a blank resume for 15 years,
and overnight gets
a knock on the door.
And her husband is arrested.
He's had a great job.
They had a fancy house.
She loved being with
her three girls.
And he got arrested for
a white collar crime.
And the civil trial
turned criminal.
And he ends up going
away for six years.
Imagine, she's in her community.
Her assets are frozen.
She literally can't go to
the ATM to go buy groceries,
and is so mortified
and embarrassed.
And so what do you
do in that moment?
Can you imagine
trying to go get a job
to support three kids
when you have nothing
on your resume for 15 years?
So she hired herself as
a Stella & Dot stylist.
In the five years since, she's
earned over a million bucks.
She's paid for her three
daughters to go to college.
She's paid off the mortgage.
Her husband just
got out of prison.
She stayed with him.
So certainly for in
good times and bad.
He admits to wrongdoing,
but he's still
fundamentally a good
person and she loves
him, is staying married to him.
And I think that ability to tap
into that strength in yourself
and go do something is
just this recognition
that that well of strength
was there all along.
You could use it even if
you're not in a crisis,
even if you're not
suffering from shame
and the ATM isn't
working anymore.
So I think that
there's several stories
like that, and many more
that I absolutely love.
And do I have time to
tell you one last story?
JESSE HAINES: Yes, definitely.
JESSICA HERRIN: This is
one of my favorite ones,
because I think the average age
in this room is-- I don't know,
it's dark out
there-- maybe in 30s?
Is that all right?
Is that a good guess?
I think when people think, here
I am, is it too late for me?
And what have I
done in my career?
And I've already gotten this
degree and I've gotten this.
I've been here.
I've invested this
time in this company.
Here I am.
Can I do anything next?
There's the story of this
woman Helen who was a nurse.
And she was raised in
a time before Title IX
where women were
made to be athletes
or to be in the work world.
She was raised to-- she
did have a job as a nurse,
but she wanted to get
married and have kids and be
a homemaker.
So she did get married.
She married well.
She married a younger man
who was the oral surgeon
that she was a nurse
for, her husband Norm.
And when she went to
retire, he went to retire,
he wanted to start
running to get into shape.
And she had never-- she'd been a
smoker for 25 years, never run,
thought this sounded like hell.
But she did it because
she wanted to be with him.
So they ran a fifth of
a mile in their backyard
the first day to
train for this 10K.
And she hated it,
I mean absolutely
like side splitting
hated it, and thought,
all right, I'm going to
do this 10K for you Norm,
but then that's it.
And when she
finished, she thought
she'd never do it again.
But he wanted to keep doing
it, so she kept doing it.
So she's 55, smoked
over 25 years.
Then at some point
she started realizing
that she wasn't running for
him and she kind of liked it,
and she started
running for herself.
And since then, she's almost 90.
She's run a marathon
on every continent
except for Antarctica.
She holds almost every
record in the world
for being an ultra marathoner.
This woman has put octogenarian,
grandmother, exsmoker,
and Tahoe Triple record
holder in the same sentence.
And it is unbelievably
mind blowing.
It's really the inspiration
for the running world.
Her name's Helen Klein.
If you're a runner, you
might know who she is.
But to me, the idea that you
can go on to, at the age of 55,
you can inspire the world--
literally the world--
in doing something that the
first time you did it you
hated it so much that
you wanted to quit
and thought you'd
never do it again,
and she started by going
a fifth of a mile a day.
So if you can do
something that you suck at
and that you actually
dislike and believe
that you can go on
and inspire the world,
and getting started in your own
backyard, a fifth a mile a day,
I think that's pretty powerful.
JESSE HAINES: That's
an amazing story.
So to wrap up, what is your--
obviously this whole book
is about finding
your extraordinary
and it's just giving
a lot of advice.
But to Googlers
here, I guess sort of
if there was one key
takeaway that you
would want to make sure
that they would walk away
from this conversation
with, what would that be?
JESSICA HERRIN: Obviously
it's right there
in the message of
the book, which
is that you are extraordinary.
You were never ordinary.
You were never meant to
just live a quiet life.
And that opportunity
is all around you,
and that includes
right here at Google.
You don't have to
radically change
the course of your
life or the position
that you have in order to
go do something even more
extraordinary and reach
your full potential.
You have to approach your
existing circumstances
with that passion, with that
path, with the perseverance.
So everything
that's in that book
is as much for someone
who's leading in the role
that they have rather
than thinking hey, I've
got to snap out of this
and start a business.
I actually think that
that's not for most people.
As my sibling once told me in a
way that only a sibling can is
don't expect other
people to do what you do.
You're the one that's weird.
And she's right.
So what your [INAUDIBLE]
that you're doing,
it's not less than.
I think especially
at Google you live
in this very
entrepreneurial culture
where it's very cool to
go out there and start
a company from scratch.
I don't think that any
other choice is less cool.
The diversity amongst
us is beautiful.
And your choice of
what you're doing
is incredibly valid and awesome.
And what this book is about is
helping unleash every potential
that you have into your choices
if they're right for you
so that you love your life more.
Not only that you
accomplish more,
but that you actually create
the definition of success that
includes happiness and joy.
JESSE HAINES: Awesome.
Jessica, thank you so
much for being with us.
JESSICA HERRIN: Thank you.
JESSE HAINES: And
congratulations on the book.
JESSICA HERRIN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks for having me.